[Musique]
[Rires]
chaque groupe
notre entreprise est véritablement
centrées sur la volonté de trouver des
solutions pour améliorer la vie des
handicapés et leur donner accès à la
satiété
[Rires]
baptisée personnes handicapées sont
souvent confinées chez elles
rien de ce que l'on trouve évident n'est
simple pour une personne qui ne peut pas
marcher
une chaise roulante doit être la
continuité de votre corps comme un
membre artificiel des lunettes ou un
appareil auditif
il faut donc l'adapter à chacun est-ce
que l'inclinaison te convient
et tu peut avaler correctement dans
cette position d'accord c'est bien
[Musique]
news corp j'étais sculpteuse une artiste
qui vivait pour et par les belles choses
et quand ma seconde fille aînée elle
était atteinte d'un très lourd handicap
on m'a conseillé de la mettre dans une
maison spécialisée de refaire un enfant
et de continuer ma vie cela allait
contre tout ce en quoi je croyais alors
j'ai commencé à travailler avec elle
pour essayer d'apporter un sens et un
confort à sa vie la première chaise que
j'ai construite mais ma fille a tout
bousculé en moi elle ne pouvait pas
s'asseoir
elle ne pouvait pas bouger elle ne
pouvait même pas regarder dans la
direction qu'elle souhaitait en lui
construisant une chaise qui lui a porté
un maintien adapté à son handicap c'est
comme si on lui avait donné des ailes
elle devenait indépendante elle pouvait
aller se servir à boire quand elle avait
soif on lui avait donné la possibilité
d'être enfin une personne
[Musique]
c'était il ya vingt ans depuis shauna a
décidé de se consacrer entièrement au
confort des personnes handicapées elle
constate que les chaises roulantes
traditionnels sont mal adaptés à la
plupart des patients et contribuer à
aggraver leur handicap alors schoonaert
invente la chaise roulante fait sur
mesure l'état si ses genoux se croise on
va lui fabriquer un blockhaus pour
équilibrer sa position ses genoux ne se
croiseront plus ce qui lui évitera de
développer d'autres malformations en
grandissant chaque enfant a une manière
complètement différente évoluer la
manière dont ils se développent dépend
en grande partie de sa position et de
son maintien dans sa chaise une mauvaise
mise en place et c'est la colonne qui se
déforment et les souffrances du handicap
et qui augmente les thérapeutes sont là
pour surveiller le développement de
l'enfant
les chaises sont modulables et réadapté
en permanence en fonction de leurs
besoins
c'est un peu trop large pour lui il
faudrait le coupé
on doit lui rajouter des coussins
latéraux
ils éviteront que son corps ne
s'affaisse ou ne parte sur le côté on en
câlins sur la gauche un autre sur la
droite
cela lui donnera un bon alignement en
évitant ainsi la dégradation des malades
les économies faites aux systèmes de
santé sont considérables le premier en
avoir été convaincu ce fut nelson
mandela qui a financé en personne la
première chaise construite par shauna
une chaise qu'elle dessine à démonta
dans son garage
aujourd'hui à la tête de 65 employés et
là une usine et un centre de
développement qui produisent en moyenne
6000 chaise par an 30 % de son personnel
est handicapé
et robin green et si on le met comme
cela on va lui donner trop d'angle
positionner les coussins plus haut et ça
y est adapté aux malades
les chefs doivent encore subir quelques
modifications pour cette fois ci être
adapté au terrain car dans les
bidonvilles où les zones rurales les
chefs traditionnels ne servent quasiment
à rien cette chaîne n'est pas adaptée
pour une personne qui doit se déplacer
sur un terrain irrégulier et ce terrain
n'est pas si chaotique c'est une simple
promenade au parc sur cette chaise qui
est une chaise standard où il tombe sur
cette chaise il est assis bien trop loin
de l'axé des roues et il n'y a pas une
base suffisamment longue
donc il peut basculer facilement vers
l'avant regardez il ne peut pas se
débrouiller sur ce terrain cela peut
mettre sa vie en danger
alors que l'autre chef va traverser le
même terrain sans aucun effort la
différence principale c'est qu'il a une
base beaucoup plus longue
les roues sont plus grande est sa
position au dessus des roues et modifié
l' axe est juste sous ses fesses déchets
souterrain qui soulage les patients en
2009 shauna est élu entrepreneur social
de l'année en afrique du sud en pleine
crise de l'économie mondiale
elle voit son chiffre d'affaires
augmenter de 65 % calculé notre retour
sur investissement on mesure les
économies que l'on fait faire aux
systèmes de santé et aussi on évalue les
impacts que l'on peut avoir sur la
société
combien de personnes peuvent retrouver
un travail combien peuvent retourner à
l'école et retrouver une situation
[Musique]
notre clinique se déplace dans les
écoles spécialisées dans toute l'afrique
du sud et propose des formations sur
place nous allons dans les classes et
nous formons les enseignants et les
aides soignants on leur apprend
certaines techniques et on leur fournit
du matériel spécialisé et adapté on veut
être sûr que ce matériel pourra aider
chaque enfant à mieux travailler
si les enfants sont mal tenus dans leur
chaise il dépense toute leur énergie et
leur concentration pour se maintenir en
place pour tenir leurs livres avec une
bonne chaise et sont libérés du poids de
leur corps ils peuvent se concentrer sur
les cours
elles obtiennent de bien meilleurs
résultats formation interventions dans
les écoles dans les hôpitaux dans les
centres pour enfants mais chemin
s'arrête pas là dans les bidonvilles du
cap
elle fait du porte à porte pour venir en
aide aux handicapés qui n'ont pas les
moyens de se déplacer
bonjour comment ça va aujourd'hui bien
merci
on te l'a apportée
alors te voilà pour moi le social
business est la manière la plus évidente
de mener une entreprise
il s'agit d'apporter quelque chose de
positif dans la vie des gens et de
travailler ensemble pour une cause plus
grande
ce qui n'empêche pas de gagner de
l'argent et de continuer à se développer
a estimé le business doit ajouter de la
valeur au monde
sinon à quoi bon faire merci merci
[Musique]